اعلن واتساب ماسنجر عن بدء تطبيقي اداه
جديده لتطبيق اي اجراءات رقابه تفرضها
الدول عليها الاداء الجديده صممت بشكل
اساسي للبلدان التي تقوم بشكل مؤقت او
دائم لتقييد الوصول الى الواتساب
الوصول الى خوادم التطبيق مما يمنع
المستخدمين من ارسال الرسائل او تلقيها في
تفاصيل هذه الاداء الجديده يتوقع ان يدمج
واتساب في الايام القليله المقبله خيارا
يسمح باختيار خادم همم خادما يدوي بروكسي
يدوي او خادم يعمل لك وسيط وينقل البيانات
تلقائيا الى خوادم واتساب ونظرا لان هذه
الخوادم الوكيله لها عنوان مختلف عن
واتساب فمن الصعب على الرقابه تحديدها او
حذرها
للمزيد حول هذه الخطوه تنضم الينا من
ولايه قناتك الامريكيه تشينا ماي ارون
الباحثه في اداره منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
والمديره التنفيذيه لمشروع مجتمع
المعلومات سيده تشنمي ما اهميه هذه الخطوه
التي تقدم عليها واتساب
واتساب
المجتمعيه مثلا في ايران ان تكون قادره
على الاستمرار في التواصل باستخدام وصف
حتى لو ان الحكومه تقوم باعاقه او فرض قيو
وال- اا
كان رد من الحكومه الايرانيه مثلا بغلقي
هذا التطبيق عن طريق استخدام
الاجهزه بالوكاله وحركات بالوكاله
طيب ماذا عن ماذا قانونيه هذه الخطوه
بالنظر للقوانين المحليه في هذه الدول
ما نظرنا في ايطاليا القوانين المحليه
والقوانين التي مررتتها الحكومه هي تكون
خرقا لذلك لكن اذا ما نظرنا الى هذا الامر
في مساله حقوق الدستوريه للاشخاص بامكاننا
ان نحجز ان واتساب يحاول ان يدعم حريه
التعبير حول التعبير الاشخاص والشعوب
لانهما يحصل الان هو ان هنالك حركه
مجتمعيه من اجل حمايته حقوق النساء مثلا
لما يحصل في ايران وغلق هذه
التطبيق سيجعل من الصعب المحتاجين التنسيق
مع بعضهم البعض مثلا لكي يكون جزءا من
الحركه وايضا سيمنعهم من التواصلي مع
الاشخاص الذين هم خارج البلاد واخبارهم
الذي يحصل داخل البلد
وبالتالي هذا هو الوضع الان هلا يعني ان
الشركات
الاجنبيه هي في وضع ان صعب لانها مجبره
على ان
همم
طلبته الحكومه وعليها ان تختار بين الشعب
وبين الحكومه وهذا خيار صعب
واتساب بهذه الطريقه عندما يكون محظور
محليا هل هويه من يستخدم هذا التطبيق في
هذه الحاله مصانه وسريه
واتساب واتساب
لا يعرف
رسائل بين الاطراف وفي بيان امم قالوا ان
استخدام هذه الحسابات بالوكاله التي تمكن
الناس من الالتفاف على هذا الحظر سيحفظ
هذا التفسير التشفير عفوا بمعنى لم يعرفها
هويه الاشخاص لكن بما ان الشركه لديها
سياسه استخدام الاسم الحقيقي بمعنى ان
بامكانها ان تكتشف هويه المستخدمين عن
طريق ارقامي بمعنى انه لما كنت اتحدث معك
على واتساب قد لا يعرف واتساب
على تواصل مع بعضنا البعض
واعتقد ان هذا الامر سيكون مساعده للشركه
في تفسيرها كيفيه الاحتفاظ بسريهاويتي
المتحدثين او المتواصلين لان هذا مهم خاصه
في سياق الحركه التي تجري في ايران
الباحثه في اداره منصات التواصل
الاجتماعيه والمديره التنفيذيه لمشروع
المجتمع المعلومات